whose ester band celebrity crush it
loves them Mila Kunis or Tom Cruise the
quicker we move on from that the better
I've got checkin an Esther ban force
India's driving dream team we're gonna
play a little game I like to call
teammates but we're gonna really test
how well you guys know each other okay
the aim of the game is to get exactly
the same answer
how old is surgeon holiday surgeon I
mean you should know this one all right
okay
one two three and they said 28 what is
the correct answer
I might give you minus points for this
come on I said seven you told me 28 I
thought you were fair guy what is
Esteban's hometown I can see this is
gonna end
who's better on the dance floor so you
go check out he got some moves and so
bad that I think he's bit whose bet with
the ladies all the stories that I hear
we'll keep it PG for our audience okay
here's the man with the linen if checker
wasn't a Formula One driver what would
he be a lawyer or a porn star these are
vastly different careers you got that
one right
who's Esther band celebrity crush he
loves him
Mila Kunis or Tom Cruise the quicker we
move on from that the better who is the
better driver
[Music]
we waited too long can you explain your
reasoning behind this was it because if
she's not saying it's him the best it's
an issue who is your new favorite
sponsor of Sahara force in their sport
back to put my buttons my way you guys
I've forgotten the score you did
terribly I've been just ends up for the
sport Bible
you've been crap crap
[Music]